sometimes things do not go well that
that's self-evident but here's the rub
sometimes when things are not going well
it's precisely that which is most valued
that is the cause why it's because the
world is revealed through the template
of your values if the world you are
seeing is not the world you want
therefore it's time to examine your
values it's time to rid yourself of your
current presuppositions there's a famous
experiment that I've alluded to a couple
of times I believe in this lecture
series the invisible gorilla experiment
and in the invisible gorilla experiment
there's two teams of players each with
three members one dressed in block and
the other dressed in white and each team
is passing a basketball back and forth
to the team members and milling about
you see a video of them doing so they
basically fill the video screen and the
White team is passing a basketball to
the white team members and the Black
team is passing a basketball to the
Black team members and your job as as
far as the experimenter is concerned is
for you to count the number of times
that the black black team yes black team
passes the basketball back and forth so
that's what you do so now you have an
ambition and a name and a value and the
ambition and the aim and the value
they're all the same thing and that is
to perform well at the task now the
thing that's so cool about this and this
is really so cool it's just unbelievably
it's just unbelievable that this is the
case it's like a complete validation of
a certain element of the Buddhist
worldview so they passed the ball for a
couple of minutes and then the
experimenter says to you how many and
you say 15 and because you're happy and
you're happy with yourself because
you've been paying attention and and the
experimenter says yeah that's right or
maybe not maybe you missed one and then
the experimenter says did you see the
gorilla and half of you say what what
what gorilla like really and he and the
experimenter says yes and then he
rewinds it and plays the video and like
a minute and a half into the three
video sure enough in walks this guy in a
gorilla suit six foot three here so
stands in the middle of the game right
in the middle of the game the same size
as the players perfectly obviously
evident beats his chest for like a
second and a half and then sort of
saunters off and half the people who
watch the video don't see the gorilla
which is absolutely shocking and what
that means is that your ambitions blind
you to the nature of reality
now they illuminate some reality but
they blind you to most of it and that's
fine because you're not there's not a
lotta you in some ways you're a very
pinpoint thing like a laser beam and so
you just can't be attending to
everything all the time but one of the
things that you might ask yourself once
you know that is that if you're
suffering dreadfully then one
possibility is that you're so fixed on
the point you're so fixed on a point the
fact that you're so fixed on the point
that you're fixed on might be integrally
related to why things are going so
catastrophic aliy wrong now perhaps not
because you know there's a lot of
arbitrariness about life and perhaps you
suffer even when you don't deserve to
that seems to happen in the book of Job
for example because job is a good guy
and God has a bet with Satan which seems
like another relatively nasty thing to
do to let Satan just torture him and he
does quite nicely to see if he'll turn
against God and it seems like a rather
playground sort of thing for God to
engage in but the point is is that even
in a document like the Old Testament
there's ample
suggestion that sometimes people just
get wiped out and hurt even if they're
living good moral lives aiming properly
and all that there's an arbitrariness in
life you that's not it erratic low but
it's possible that it's what you're
clinging to that's hurting you and it's
even possible that's the thing that
you're clinging to the hardest that's
hurting you the most that could easily
be someone you love like lots of times I
see people in therapy and they're
miserable for
in another sometimes it's because they
have a very close relationship with a
family member and that just isn't
working you know the family member for
the sake of simplicity will say is not
really oriented towards helping them
have a good life the family member is
instead oriented towards making them as
bloody miserable as you can possibly
make anyone and and what would you say
exploiting the the bond between family
members in order to enable that and then
sometimes the sacrifice that's necessary
is either merely distancing yourself
from that person sometimes substantively
and sometimes seriously distancing
yourself from like we don't talk anymore
ever and so that's pretty damn rough and
it hurts and all of that but but it's a
good example of the fact that sometimes
in order to extract yourself from the
miserable bit of chaos that you happen
to be in meshed in you have to let go of
what you love best if the world you are
seeing is not the world you want
therefore it's time to examine your
values that's really worth it's really
worth thinking about you know because
the alternative to is to curse fate
right because if it isn't you there's
nothing you can do to change there isn't
something you're doing that's wrong then
it's faith itself it's the world itself
it's other people let's say because
they're a huge part of the world or it's
the nature of the world itself or or its
God himself in whatever form you either
believe in or don't believe in because
it's fundamentally all the same in this
sort of situation that I'm describing so
and one of the things that's really
interesting and I mentioned this before
about the Israelites in the Old
Testament is that they they got this
right it's really something because what
happens to the Israelites over and over
in the Old Testament is that they get
all puffed up about how wonderful they
are and then they make moral errors
because they're arrogant and then God
comes along and just cuts them into
pieces for like generation after
generation and then they wobble back to
their feet and but they always maintain
the same attitude which is
we did something wrong we did something
wrong it's like it's like it's like an
axiom rather than an observation is that
if we're not if things are not laying
themselves out for us as they should be
then we cannot curse god we have to look
to ourselves well and you think well why
not curse god yes maybe it's his fault
and that's a really good question and
one of the things that I've tried to
figure out over the last 30 years is
well why not just curse God because
there is this arbitrary element to
existence and we are vulnerable and
there is a plenty of suffering and
things are unfair like there's problems
right there's injustice and unfairness
and all of these things and and endless
suffering so why not just lay at the
feet of God and the whether God exists
or not in some sense by the way with
regards to the metaphysics of this
particular discussion is not relevant
it's the point remains the same either
way and the answer is as far as I can
tell that if you refuse to take on the
responsibility yourself and you attempt
it to lay it at the feet of either
society or being itself then you
instantly start to act in a way that
makes everything much worse not only for
you but for everyone else and maybe even
for being itself and so no it's not
helpful now if you're if you decide that
it's you you've got the problem maybe
that's not even true like maybe you are
someone who's being tortured by the bet
between God and Satan and like too bad
for you if that happens to be the case
but it still seems to be the appropriate
thing for a human being who's standing
on his or her own two feet in a proper
manner to take the responsibility on for
themselves regardless of the counter
arguments that might be made against it
that's really something it's time to rid
yourself of your current presuppositions
I also think of that it's a Deadwood
issue you know one of the things you see
with motifs like the the pear the
Phoenix remember when Harry Potter goes
off to fight
he's like st. George he goes off to
fight the the hell is that thing the bow
that turns you to stone when you look at
its a dragon for all intents and
purposes its guarding a virgin for
what's-her-name for just not Virginia
it's close to that though Ginny Ginny
Ginevra right which is a variant of
virgin and very introvert Virginia well
when he gets bitten by the by the dragon
and and and poisoned that's the dragon
of chaos right the thing that turns you
to stone when you look at it when he
gets bitten by it then he's going to die
and yeah well if you get bitten by the
thing that turns you to stone when you
look at it if it bites you man if you're
not dead you're gonna wish you are it's
one of the two and then the Phoenix
flies in and cries tears into the wound
and that heals them and the Phoenix is
the thing that allows the dead wood to
burn off occasionally let's say well
it's I think it's once every hundred
years with the Phoenix and of course
it's pretty dramatic the whole damn bird
has to go up in flames and then there's
nothing left but an egg but there's a
very serious message there too which is
that you know you can compare yourself
in some sense to a forest fire to a
forest you know in a forest has to burn
now and then for the dead wood to clear
so that the forest can actually maintain
its continued existence and if you stop
the forest from burning for a prolonged
period of time which happened in the
United States when they were trying to
manage the forest fires too tightly then
all that happens is the dead wood
accumulates and accumulates and
accumulates until the whole damn forest
is dead wood and then lightning hits it
and it burns so hot that it burns the
topsoil off and then there's nothing
left nothing grows and so that's a good
moral lesson which is don't wait too
long to let the damn dead wood burn off
you know maybe a little
self-immolation on a daily basis might
be preferable to burning yourself all
the way down to the bedrock you know
once every twenty years or so because
maybe there won't be anything left of
you when you do that and you know that
happens to people all the time I've seen
that happen to people many many times
the dead wood accumulates the mess
around them gathers the chaos that they
haven't dealt with accumulates and then
one day the spark comes and they burn so
far and so fast that there's not enough
left of them to recover and then they're
the people who've been eaten by the
beasts they're they're people who've
been eaten by the
and now we're inside its belly another
very common archetypal motif and while
maybe a hero will come along and rescue
them or maybe they'll just stay in there
forever and that's a precursor to the
idea of Hell and it's not something I
would recommend so a little medicine on
a regular basis is a lot better too than
total emulation on terms other than your
own sporadically